uh it's going to expand to the entire
planet
I mean it just is happening right now
let me I didn't share with you in the
earlier part I thought you know but let
me just share with you
there are scientists today uh
one of them particularly I will quote
uh Johann rockstrom from the Potsdam
Institute in Berlin where he is the
director of it and he and some other
scientists have proffered that uh we
could well be at
or past
all or some of five tipping points right
now
those five tipping points are number one
the coral reefs
number two the baron seed ice number
three the permafrost
which is particularly concerning to
military operations because as
permafrost thaws in various places the
land begins to move and disrupt you know
runways airports various facilities
buildings are cracking you can go up in
in the northern part of Russia and other
places and see the effects but the the
greater damage is the release of methane
in massive amounts and methane is 20 to
80 times more destructive than CO2 so
this release of methane that's occurring
because of the permafrost doing who
reverses the permafrost thought
I we don't know how we don't have the
power to do that so that's a Tipping
Point that is something that you may
find your is irreversible but the two
most compelling
are the Arctic and the Antarctic yeah
now I went up to the Arctic in the
Antarctica Secretary of State visited
both listened to the scientists stood on
the ice sheet of the Arctic watching a
torrential river flowing underneath the
ice out into the ocean of the melting
ice it was 70 degrees Fahrenheit above
normal in the Arctic last year it was
last summer it was a hundred degrees
Fahrenheit above normal in the Antarctic
and and you can see the disruption in
the ice sheet just visibly as you fly
over it uh and and vast amounts of it
have been breaking off and going out to
sea and melting I I saw one Fjord where
the calving of excuse me 86 million
metric tons of ice Falls each day
calving into the ocean and then going
out to melt we are seeing a higher rate
of sea level rise than was predicted
earlier and if the entire ice sheet over
the next Century Century and a half a
long period of time obviously but within
the lifetime of some people uh you know
born now today
uh uh you can you can see levels of of
disruption that are coming at us we have
no ability to do anything to except
adapt
or build resilience
so you know that that 86 million metric
tons
folks there's enough water on a daily
basis floating out in the ocean to
supply the greater New York Region the
greater Connecticut region the greater
New Jersey region you know a lot of
people with their water needs for an
entire year so it sounds very much as if
we can see the most severe impacts in
perhaps the hottest warmest places in
the world at present Africa and we can
see the initial effects of climate
change in the colder but the impacts in
terms of the Strategic environment is
going to impact across the whole world I
mean there is no corner of the world
well let me
that's a very good point
that's a very good point I'll just build
on it slightly
in sub-Saharan Africa
you have 48 nation states
that produce zero
point five five percent of all the
emissions of the world
18 of the 25 most impacted places in the
world are in Africa
so that's where you're going to have a
massive impact the entire food
production capacity is is at risk it
hasn't happened it's not happening
tomorrow but it's at risk of imploding
and then you will have literally tens of
millions of people on the Move banging
on the door of Europe or banging on some
door where they think they'd get in have
a better life uh in addition
there are 20 countries
UK and U.S among them
that are responsible for about 76
percent of all the emissions
so that's really where we have to get it
right
those 20 countries need to step up
because unless they do the rest of the
world is really going to be suffering
the consequences and I think it's going
to be an extraordinarily disruptive
Global community at that point in time
well you mentioned of course the impact
of food and grain on the most vulnerable
countries already and uh you know
perhaps we've seen a foreshadowing of
that already with the Ukrainian War and
the supply of grain to African countries
I mean is that the sort of thing that
you could expect to see more of yes
absolutely there's no question about it
yesterday on the front page of the New
York Times there was a big photograph
above the fold of the Mekong Delta with
with huge expanses rice paddies and the
rice crop is threatened there threatened
in South Asia it's threatened in India I
mean and that's a staple of food for you
know billions of people
so that is at risk it's happening now
and it's partly happening because the
warming and the increased acidification
it's also happening because of
irresponsible damning
the building of dams on the Milky River
all the way from China down through Laos
Cambodia has been just out of any realm
of reasonableness without regard to
Downstream impacts and of course the
Mekong Delta is the final Downstream
destination
okay secretary Kenny can I just focus on
one you mentioned 18 countries is one of
those that you're concerned of in in
Africa Sudan I I asked this simply
because this is a very live situation
here I just recall that you and I first
met I think when we tried to put the
fire out in Yemen and there are so many
patches of the world where the West has
sort of wandered into Afghanistan Iraq
Somalia Libya uh and so forth
sudanes is a live example of where we
could be doing a lot more to assist in
stabilizing that country before things
got out of control but the addition of
climate change and what's happening in
that country is going to really compound
the challenges there if we don't lean
into it
it will it will compound Mr chairman but
uh I I think more I mean Sudan South
Sudan uh Ethiopia that entire area the
Horn of Africa is going to as a whole be
enormously impacted but also uh the
Sahel
and uh you know these are places that
will be greatly affected as I said we're
losing you know they're 10 million
people a year who die from extreme heat
and we're witnessing places now right
now yesterday the last few days in India
uh they're massive they're millions of
people sleeping Outdoors uh in hopes of
of you know getting through the heat
because it's 30 degrees Centigrade at
night time
and we're seeing unheard of temperatures
during the day so this is happening
faster than a lot of people anticipated
and I think that's something we really
need to take note of last summer in
Europe I think the Rhine River was down
to inches in in some places
um we at Lake Powell and Lake Mead which
feed the Hoover Dam electricity plant uh
was it record low levels insufficient to
produce the electricity water was
insufficiently uh cool it was it was too
hot in France so it wasn't able to cool
the nuclear plants I mean you can you
can start
a long list of the of the impacts that
are occurring today which many
scientists will tell you are bigger and
faster
in their happening than have been
predicted
is it also fair to say that
um good governance uh why security or
utility of the Armed Forces is going to
be challenged in these countries where
dictators or authoritarian States will
be doing ever more taking every more
Extreme Measures to look after
themselves to stay in power rather than
being able to handle these these threats
perhaps wisely uh and cognitively
Mr chairman history is full of
so-called leaders who find people and
places to blame
for their inability to be able to
provide for their people or willingness
to provide for their people
and uh that is why it is a threat that's
why the climate crisis is a threat
multiplier there was a book written a
number of years ago I think it's called
water wars
and uh it it lays out the case for which
and already you could you have conflict
I mean you have tribes fighting over
wells in various parts of the world and
as the water patterns change
significantly leaders uh will fight to
provide for their people and may even
and have they have historically fought
over various water bodies uh I wouldn't
eliminate that as one of the risks that
we face if we don't respond adequately
uh thank you very much indeed let's now
turn to uh Ukraine and perhaps what's
happening there as to how uh the battle
over food and oil supplies things like
that is is is impacting there um Robert
do you want to take that thought
yes chair we know we've mentioned
Ukraine uh briefly already
a section just in terms of the context
of grain Supply and I'm particularly
concerned about the security uh
implications uh that we'll see not just
from that we'll see from climate and
then from the uh the trade conflict that
comes after that I mean I wondered as
well whether I could ask you about China
and how we approach China because this
is clearly a key country that we've got
to engage with in terms of reducing uh
Global emissions but there's also
massive strategic importance that they
have there in terms of exporting uh
capturing processing vital materials
including things that go into ours and
your uh fighter aircraft
yes uh China you don't know
is a is uh critical to any solution
because China today is
about 30 percent and growing
uh not quite 30 yet but growing in the
percentage of emissions of the world
uh an example I mean China's nearing 30
percent we're around 10 percent and
declining
um and
the EU as a whole is somewhere around I
don't know seven percent or somewhere
around there but
um and obviously you're no longer in the
EU but I I don't know precisely
you know
alone your emissions don't reach the
levels of those other countries so China
even as it is
uh building new coal plants
uh is also deploying more renewable
uh capacity than any other country in
the world
China is also the largest manufacturer
of that capacity than any place in the
world
and so uh that's why China Bloom so
large on both sides of this because we
Des you know we we do need China to be
at the table and working in a
Cooperative way with us and we need to
work cooperatively with China it's a you
know we've got to find a way to deal
with the climate crisis and separate it
from the other issues which are
obviously issues of enormous concern to
many people in the world and there are a
lot of them it's not just some tiny
little list there there's a there's a
list of items uh which from nuclear
weapons to cyber uh Warfare and cyber
theft and and the economy and uh you
know you can run through the long list
that's not a challenge here the problem
is that um
uh
right now there has not been uh for a
period of time there hasn't been uh the
level of communication that we had
previously as we worked with China on
this my hopes are I know President Biden
is very much uh hopeful that there could
be some throwing in the relationship
he's working at it it's our hope
that sometime in the next weeks they'll
be able to be some discussions that can
begin to move us in a better Direction
but bottom line uh there are I mentioned
20 countries
at the top of the list of those 20
countries are China the United States
Russia India Indonesia Brazil Mexico
South Africa uh you know a group of
countries that have big economies
and that are also major emitters
none no no country
can solve this problem by itself
that is why we've had 27 meetings of the
conference of the parties under the U.N
process and and that's why we're going
to have the 28th in December in Dubai in
the UAE and our hope is that this one
could go further than we've gone
previously in pinning down the level of
ambition we need for mitigation because
you can't adapt your way out of this
crisis you you've got to reduce the
emissions and I think Mr chairman you
mentioned earlier the longevity issue
here uh these emissions stay active
in the atmosphere until you take them
out and do something with them that
requires direct capture and right now we
don't have that we have the technology
but it's massive it's very expensive and
in bringing it to scale is exceedingly
difficult and even if we got to Net Zero
by 2050
we still have to suck a trillion six or
so
uh uh million tons
a trillion tons excuse me of of CO2 out
of the atmosphere okay so we Face a
Monumental challenge here because the
damage continues to be done no matter
what okay again
I think we have the ability Mr chairman
if we apply ourselves
uh and bring ourselves together in
consortia and begin to work more
intensively uh that's our best shot at
being able to do what we need to do
thank you for that Gavin Robinson
thank you very much Mr chairman Mr
secretary I think you're fairly
indicating that President Biden has the
aspiration of throwing relations and
encouraging movement particularly with
China and you know that
this is a global Quest but not all are
equally committed to it so what more do
you believe the United States or
ourselves or other developed Nations can
do to deal with the resentment that
abounds in many of the countries that
you have indicated within that top 20
who look on at the developed West with a
level of resentment and say well you
boys for Generations have benefited from
using fossil fuels and you've grown
economically and some of the other
countries within that 20 are saying we
just want our opportunity to do that as
well and are not as invested in the
challenges associated with
ever-increasing temperature do you have
a plan rather than just throwing
relations to incentivize those countries
to make that significant difference
well the best incentive of all is the
fact that if we don't do it uh you know
every country in the world is going to
be equally impacted significantly
impacted in in
existential ways and if existential
choices don't motivate you I'm not sure
anything will
but the reality is that uh
let's be I mean it's really important to
have a fact-based conversation here
yes Great Britain began the Industrial
Revolution the United States picked it
up and certainly Europe and and some
other countries throughout the 1900s
develop their economies and went uh
merrily along their way filling the
atmosphere with these fumes
and only a couple of times during that
period of time did some
some Visionary people
uh venture to suggest that this could be
very damaging process the scientists the
Swedish scientists are genius in the
late 1800s suggested it in more modern
times Rachel Carson wrote about the
potential damage being done some others
but it really wasn't until 1988
when Jim Hansen a NASA scientist
testified before the U.S Congress
that the climate crisis is happening
it's here it's with us now that's when
governments on a global basis began to
concentrate and focus and in 1992
we all came together in Rio and we
passed an agreement which was voluntary
that we were going to address emissions
in the climate crisis since then we've
had 27 meetings of those parties the
28th coming now and we have yet to pull
the world together in in an organized
fashion that's really guaranteed to get
the job done and and even during those
years
my friends during those years of the uh
you know from the warning on
a lot of other countries have gone out
and willfully used coal because that's
all they had
so the truth is that you know all of
those largest countries
have been responsible for doing things
uh to their own climate and to the
climate of the of the planet as a result
of the ways they have chosen to propel
their vehicles Heat their homes light
their factories and businesses and so
forth that's that's where it is and and
you can't you're not going to gain
anything here by pointing fingers saying
well you guys started in the 1800s yeah
but you can measure all of the emissions
between 18 you know 98 and 1900 and 1988
and they pale compared to the emissions
that have been going up into the
atmosphere from 1992 till now during the
time we had an agreement to supposedly
do something about this so I think that
we've got to stop finger-pointing and
pull together countries that can do more
need to do more countries that have an
economy that could put money into this
effort need to put money into the effort
people who have the Technologies need to
deploy them and come together and and
and and further develop technologies
that are going to save us from ourselves
thank you Kevin conscious Gavin's
question a bit further because I think
it's very interesting
to recognize that how much of the the
relationship or the or the poor
relationship between the world's two
superpowers perhaps is playing he spoke
about the importance of cooperation
But ultimately the relationships between
United States and China are not good I
mean that came out when that balloon
went down in February uh the Chinese
balloon it was reported that there were
no back channels uh with the united with
uh with China arguably so you are the
best Communicator with China you go
there on a regular basis with a very
different agenda than most others are
visiting Taiwan or you know speaking
with authority because of China's you
know military aggression its growth it's
assertion it's one built one road
programs my question is how much is this
distorting our ability to nurture the
type of relationship that we need to
persuade
China because I I've heard this before
what Gavin has said that you know
Britain poisoned the world we had our
Industrial Revolution it's now Chinese
times and their timelines are very
different to ours you know they're
saying 2006 to 2017 is when they start
to really uh you know move into to to
proper
um
the carbon neutral place and of course
Russia is then playing on that pivoting
over to sell its oil and gas because
there is no longer a western Market
because of Ukraine so you have Russia
and China choosing a very different
Avenue
surely China must recognize that they
are going to be as damaged and affected
as the rest of the world if we keep
going down this road
well look I I uh President Biden made it
very clear at the very beginning of his
administration
that the climate crisis was not
like and shouldn't be treated like the
other issues between
the United States and and and the west
and China
and and for the you know for a long
period of time we separated it uh it was
able to be separated and we could go
along a climate track which we did
fairly effectively with the with some
agreements as to what we would do but
before we could Implement those
agreements other things interfered uh
and made it more complicated I think
President Biden very much wants to go
forward the Chinese we've been I've been
talking with the Chinese uh by a video
conference in the last months uh
regrettably my counterpart she is in
what was sick for a period of time he's
much better now and and we are engaged
in conversations and he has told me that
that the Chinese now believe that it's
important for them to separate the
climate crisis from the other issues so
the other issues of the bailiwick of
Secretary of State blinken uh and and
the president and and the White House
and I try to you know keep moving along
as well as we can here to get progress
on the climate front because yes China
knows it's going to be impacted that's
why they're deploying an extraordinary
amount of renewable energy right now way
more than the rest of the world put
together
so China is currently uh you know moving
uh we would obviously like them to to do
certain things that they haven't yet
done we've talked about those whether
it's methane or or faster uh transition
but that's what we have to talk about
those are the kinds of things that are
important to sit down and hash out and
President Biden wants us to be able to
do that sooner rather than later and
that's what he's working towards the
challenge though is for you and is is
this something that you raise that
China's emissions are not coming down as
fast as they should do they are building
still building coal-fired power stations
so they're putting their own economy
above the interests or or of the the
planet how do we reconcile this because
on the one side they are making
batteries they're doing all this clean
energy things and making turbines and so
forth but on the other side they still
are very much pursuing a China first
strategy
yes uh they are Mr chairman and I think
that there are many other countries in
the world doing the same thing
uh and what we need to do is find the
common interests and the ways in which
we can actually work uh in a in a
acceptable way
uh in terms of
you know cooperating to make certain
things happen that's what we agreed to
do in Glasgow we agreed that we were
going to work on methane China agreed to
put together a methane plan uh that plan
was shown to us in trauma Sheikh they're
working on the approval of it it's one
of the things we'd like to talk with him
about in addition uh they uh also agreed
that they would try to work with us to
accelerate the transition off of coal
and I think there are many ways in which
we could actually be helpful to each
other in the exchange of information in
the ways in which we might even be able
to cooperate on the ground to to
accelerate the reduction of emissions
which we all benefit from so I think
that you know what we need to do is find
the things that we can mutually agree
could make a difference to both of us
without compromising other kinds of
things that Nations might not be willing
to compromise so
you know I I hope that can happen I know
again I say it that President Biden is
committed to trying to move us to a
better place in that dialogue but there
are some tough issues uh and and they're
on a completely different track from the
climate track which is where they ought
to be
thank you secretary uh Gavin again thank
you chair Mr secretary we've talked
about some aspects of this impacting
upon defense including the potential for
famine Mass migration and a number of
nation states maybe impacted by friction
and tension between themselves this
question is I guess more particularly
focused on defense and the impact of of
climate change and would be interested
in your assessment as to the impact of
climate change and the operability of
Defense Forces Armed Forces be it
through extreme temperatures for
personnel extreme temperatures for the
effective mobility of equipment and
ships mobility and so on and then rising
sea levels potentially impacting
outposts and defense locations based
overseas
well uh a very important question we are
already seeing impacts in in Norfolk
Virginia for instance
um
they are making plans for how to deal
with Readiness in order to get the
complement of a ship to be able to reach
the ship uh in the event of emergency
where they may be cut off as a result of
the rising sea level I was briefed on
this a number of years ago as secretary
from the Admiral in charge of the East
Coast who was talking about the
Readiness impacts that the climate
crisis presents obviously I just
mentioned the permafrost changes and so
forth there there are uh the Department
of Defense right now has said
that each year here in the states they
are seeing the consequences of
increasing incidence of flooding drought
wildfires extreme weather events on
military installations here at home
and uh uh in 2019 alone the Department
of Defense assessed that climate-related
impacts to 79 different installations in
every Geographic combatant command area
of responsibility were present and they
see these threats as only increasing so
there are many other ways in which uh
the footprint of a particular deployment
will have an impact uh and uh in 2021
the Director of National Intelligence
released a new National Intelligence
estimate on climate change which
identified a list of countries of
concern where analysts see overlapping
fragility alongside climate
vulnerability that would be worsening
over the next decades
so this has now been integrated into the
uh into the Preparatory measures taken
by our military and NATO and others in
various places and I will be doing an
event uh in in a few weeks in Brussels
with Franz Timmerman's vice president of
the European commission and Jen
stoltenberg the head of NATO the
director
the director general and this will be
focused specifically on the impacts of
climate with respect to the security and
the measures that we need to take to
respond
thank you sir thank you Robert
thank you chair uh it's actually the
this of course climate change is a uh
Global issue uh and we clearly don't
have to have Global Response as you've
touched on uh quite rightly of course
already today
um what's greater Corporation should we
be doing between ourselves U.S UK armed
forces and wider NATO to make sure we
address these challenges at that larger
level
I think sir that uh there's a great deal
of community of of uh cooperation and
communication that's been forced
obviously by Ukraine
and um it'd be hard for me to uh you
know because I'm not following it on a
day-to-day basis not my my Lane so to
speak I can't tell you all of the
refined uh particular is a one change or
another that might make a difference I
think Jen stoltenberg clearly will share
that with us when we have our meeting in
a couple of weeks but in the meantime uh
I think a simple principle the more you
can cooperate the more you're sharing
information the more you are working
together to augment capacity uh the
stronger you're going to be and I've
been personally deeply impressed by the
way in which NATO has come together I
think President Biden has provided very
important leadership from day one when
you when he came in after a period of
time where NATO had been denigrated and
criticized and attacked and neglected by
an Administration to now being a central
probably the the strongest Alliance and
implemented Alliance on the planet and
and I think that uh
is there more that can be done yes but
let's let yes stoltenberg fill in those
blanks thank you
and secretary you you spoke earlier a
little a bit about um food uh security
and the challenge is that that uh
presents I just want to turn to specific
challenge which I think I may have
raised with you uh in person we've met
over the last couple of years
um since the Ukraine uh Invasion and
that's the
um the Green Ships coming out of the
port of Odessa uh you know and uh well
aware of how critical those green ships
are we actually feel the consequence
here in the UK because of uh the uh the
uh cost of living crisis as is called
here with food inflation one-fifth of
the grain is is getting out that's all
and as hardship increases in Africa
because of climate change
should we be should we not be doing more
internationally
to ensure that five-fifths of the grain
is able to get out there's grain which
is now caught up in the silos there's uh
there's grain which is still yet to be
taken from the the farming fields and so
forth It's all there's a massive backlog
simply because the deal the UN deal has
been scribed by Russia the bully has
determined the conditions for which
those Green Ships can get out now that
was written at a time when it looked
like Odessa may even fall because that's
the way the war was heading
now you have natural Waters
international waters surely we could
perhaps through the U.N uh General
Assembly turn Odessa into a humanitarian
Safe Haven this is needed for the you
know the the Africa but and indeed
European food security too so it's a
long explanation but is there not
something more we could do to wrestle
the control uh and the movement of the
Green Ships coming out of Ukraine
uh device that obviously is a really
Central issue
uh which belongs in the United Nations
and belongs in the security Council
except that the security Council
obviously has been rendered I mean the
weakness of it has been exposed of the
consequence of the vetoes that have
taken place and the lack of its capacity
to someone which should be normally
summoned here in the absence of that
yeah the general assembly and other
things are are available tools food
clearly should not be used as a weapon
War every Declaration of decency that
has come since uh World War II when we
began to organize ourselves around a
different set of values and principles
uh which have worked pretty effectively
notwithstanding breaches here and there
and and I think that uh I think more
focus on Odessa more focus on the
what might be the best way of protecting
that channel uh might Odessa I'm really
putting the question back to you might
Odessa become a Haven uh protected uh
for the purpose of being able to make
sure we distribute the food as was
promised I think that's an important
principle to try to enforce uh again
it's not my job to be opining on which
city or which location or to become what
in this in this war that's for others
but as a matter of broad principle uh
the the food as a weapon component of
this much like the fuel is a weapon uh
it's a very clear message to all of us
it also if I just
uh
add parenthetically quickly
the the fuel issue is critical for
everybody to take note of uh you know
gas and gas elements have been using
Ukraine to push very hard to say well
we're we're the clean entity we're the
one where we're the we're going to be
the transitional fuel but transitional
has a very funny time period attached to
it like you know 25 30 and 40 years as
facilities have built out uh with that
kind of a long payout Horizon
and and and obviously unabated gas will
become its own problem going forward
unless there are hard standards put in
place about what the emissions capture
is going to need to be for that to take
place and and so if you're replacing a
coal plant or you're replacing an
oil-based fired furnace of some kind or
whatever you are you are getting and
you're doing that with gas yeah you're
getting a momentary reduction of 30 to
50 percent of emissions
but after a certain number of years 2013
the 30 certainly that's going to be have
to be uh held accountable you're going
to have to reduce those emissions so
food gas you know those basic
necessities that could not be used as
weapons in Germany has made the most
pronounced
policy statement of all by moving you
know completely away from it and
suggesting there's an alternative future
without it
and will it remains to be seen so how
that plays out
secretary thank you for that something I
would like to pursue I think we would
like to put we visited Odessa and in the
mayor of Odessa is very keen to do this
when I was in Kief only uh through four
weeks ago again it's something that they
would like to pursue as well I
appreciate it it's it's it's not
necessarily directly in your remit it's
actually something I spoke with David
Beasley about and thank you for
introducing us to him the former head of
the world food program uh he gave
evidence to our committee a very uh
Lively character and thank you for that
that introduction it was most welcome
indeed my final question is just
relating you know you have been
cautiously optimistic you've always
caveated the concern of web 1.5
degrees is going
um and saying we can do this we can
still this we can turn this around
but it does seem that we've had cop 26
Cop 27 which seem to be less successful
we've got cop 28 which you've referred
to in Dubai
when do we really need to secure real
change in the next couple of years when
it when it is even your own optimism
going to potentially run out and we
either need to face a real reality of
fundamental seismic uh you know climate
change
well I think we face that now I mean as
I said if you have five tipping points
and two of them involve the potential of
meters literally multiple meters double
digits and meters of sea level rise
that's caps that's I mean that's as good
a definition of catastrophe as you can
achieve
uh and the reality is that that is where
we are headed unless we do more about it
now why am I why do I have this measure
of of uh of optimism and of our capacity
because it is within our capacity we
have the technology necessary to achieve
our 2030 goal
we're just not deploying it rapidly
enough
and and we're not building the supply
chain rapidly enough to deploy it but
the fact is that if we did do that we
could meet the goal and during that
period of time one of these other
Technologies may come online that
completely changes the modeling and
changes the equation
so you know I I believe in that
possibility very deeply I think that uh
there's another reason I believe in it
when I started this job
in 2021
we were headed towards three degrees
3.7 degrees or so of warming
and because of what we did in Glasgow
because of what happened in Toronto
Sheikh the iea has told us
that if all of the promises made in
Glasgow and charmel Sheikh are kept
if they're all kept we would be at 1.8
degrees of warming by 2050
out of Glasgow and out of Sharma Sheikh
we could be at 1.7 degrees by 2050 if we
Implement so it says it can be done
that's only 0.2 degree off 1.5 which if
we got the coal plants closing faster if
we shifted more rapidly to Alternative
uh sources of energy uh if we began to
exploit other available uh possibilities
ranging from small nuclear reactor to uh
to the ammonia and green hydrogen Etc
we could move faster one of the things I
have seen
which which
reinforces in me this this possibility
of getting the job done
is the fact that
there are things happening that never
were measured by any of the modeling
for instance electric vehicles right now
they've taken off in ways that nobody
predicted
we hoped but nobody predicted and the
modeling did not show the rate of
transition taking place in the electric
vehicle market today if we were to
accelerate the deployment of electric
buses we're working on an effort to do
that with India now some 12 000 buses if
if we were able to accelerate
the provision of some of the critical
minerals that are necessary for the
manufacturer we're able to do more in
the manufacturer we could up our own
deployment President Biden set a goal
that by 2035 our power sector will be
carbon free
our automobile sector will be 100
electric new cars sold by 2035. that's
the goal
now whether we can achieve it or not I
don't know
but in the effort to get there we are
seeing many things happening much faster
than we anticipated and they're proving
that we still have that capacity for the
unknown change to come to the table and
and carry us over the finish line so I I
think we have to keep pushing
and the one thing I do know is
you know we are not doing what we know
we could do and what is available to us
now in technology to be able to do we're
not doing that as fast as we could
well secretary time is up but can I just
say thank you very much indeed your
passion your vision your encouragement
your leadership is very very clear to
see that was on display when you were
over here at cop 26 uh working with our
climate change president alak Sharma I
know you've been working very very
closely with uh Prince Charles as he
then was he of course he can't be so
vocal in these matters anymore but also
with David Attenborough and uh you have
been leading voices on something which
is as I stressed at the beginning the
biggest single challenge that the globe
faces but time is running out and we do
need to do more before Global conditions
uh escalate and the crisis is unfolding
the slow motion and we certainly need to
do more about it given the security
implications that we've been studying
here today but on behalf of the
committee can I say thank you very much
indeed for taking time out of your busy
schedule it's so much appreciated uh
thank you to the staff to the my
colleague as well that brings this
Committee hearing to a conclusion